Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my legends of tomorrow
episode 12 trailer video and episode 11 Easter
egg video combined.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet.
So because there's so much DC and Marvel stuff
happening I'm in a combine the.
So I don't have to do like 50 videos this
week.
So this is the trailer for Camelot 3000, is
this really weird art from the comics that
I'll explain in my episode video from this
week there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so.
Just the teaser for the Camelot episode the
Camelot 3000 storyline in the comics was this
really weird run where is this reincarnated
version of the nights of the roundtable King
Arthur that reemerge in the year 3000, so
was part of DC's continuity.
It was meant to be this really weird trippy
story now that having a lot of fun with it
in the legends of tomorrow universe you can
see that there's justice society members that
are coming back to.
I'll explain more about that at the end of
the video but we have to talk about that heat
wave intro to this past episode he killed
it who writes this crap anyway.
Seriously this is all it all started time
Masters is all screwed up to unscrewed time
we screw things up properly way the best thing
about legends of tomorrow is that if you thought
the flash was really fun and silly legends
of tomorrow.
This season has just taken that ball and completely
spiked it in the end zone this is so much
better.
See you see how it kinda fits in with the
other DC TV shows, it's meant to be this really
big fun epic swashbuckling drama across space
and time will have a talk about more the end
of the season because I think will end up
happening is is that when arrow eventually
goes off the air if they don't have another
show that's gonna take its place.
The move legends to Wednesday night it will
be a Supergirl flash and legends, and then
after that, who knows because that the black
lightning TV show that's coming.
Let's do top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs
Artie talked about the heat wave intro that
was really my number 10 heat wave in the Legion
of doom intro whereby favorite interest of
the season so far.
There's one episode that I think might be
needed.
It's called doom world it's the last episode
before the finale and I cannot wait to hear
what the intro for that is because it makes
it seem like the Legion of doom has constructed
the Spear of destiny.
They rewrite history in the legends have to
deal with their version of flashpoint and
try to fix everything rewrite reality back
to what it should be number nine was evil
rip hunter killing George Washington and just
casually like almost like he was having fun
giving all those weapons to the British soldiers
telling them how much fun it was going to
be to rewrite history and play dirty.
So number eight.
Enter the reverse flash.
I know you still not wearing the costume he
actually posted this picture from a future
episode that there filming right now with
him back in the yellow costume.
So the be plenty more reverse flash stuff
happening in future episodes.
There's eobard Thawne stuff then there's reverse
flash stuff, because of what he did to rip
Hunter's memories, for whatever reason.
Now he just completely aligned with.
The Legion of doom he feels nothing for the
legends go.
Maybe you raise some of those memories.
It seems like his motivation mostly flows
from the time Masters allowing his children
to die at the hands of Vandal Savage in for
some reason whatever memories got rewritten
he didn't get over that.
So that's why he's with.
The Legion of doom number seven was the big
giant rat call back so early in the episode
Adam's complaint heat wave.
Do you eat food everywhere and he does.
He's like Brad Pitt he's got food in his mouth
in every single scene though he complains
there's a rat on board the WaveRider.
Later they bring back after he gets stuck
being tiny running from the giant rat which
he then later gives the heatwave as a Christmas
gift.
So I love some of the pairings in this episode
now obviously there was the big pairing number
six vixen and citizen steel totally getting
it on him explaining tender her explaining
how she never got to see the end of Wizard
of Oz.
So he gives her the ruby slippers book plot
aside, just a lot of the funny moments that
they had together were great in this episode
like Kim going over the falls her calling
the seal totem and at the end of the episode
you just basically tells him to chill.
There's not can be any relationship stuff
happening here which I think is great.
I love that people are actually allowed to
have sex without being in relationships on
this TV show number five is all the craziness
on the WaveRider.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs dammit
I'm a physicist not a doctor.
So this is really Jackson's episode to step
up.
It is him versus rip hunter sort of confronted
with the idea that maybe you can't say some
people like he almost kills them, but Sara
stop them because she doesn't want to lose
a part of his soul all the Ceradyne jokes
were great I died once didn't like it too
much as making a joke about the Lazarus pit
on arrow she kind of died two more times in
this episode number four was heatwave in general
Washington they were great together you know
what it means to be a real American he basically
gives in the business and by the end of the
episode Washington is like a gentleman would
fight but I'm an American.
So let's run so now because of that, because
their burrows he totally has a statue of himself
in Washington DC that still there in present-day
so he is now one of America's founding fathers
is so great jokes like that or why love the
show so much number three was evil rip hunter
killing Sara again just being super vicious.
He was nuts when he was on the WaveRider trying
to get that spear fragment from Jack's you
see him pause for a minute when he's getting
ready to kill Sara like he's thinking about
it.
But then just as he feels nothing.
So it's definitely not an act he's been completely
rewritten as a human being which is why he
has his old accent back all of his old memories
with the exception of the ones that made him
a good person.
So the key to fixing him is getting that memory
matrix that the reverse flash stole from the
bank fall.
So they can get that back I can rewrite his
memories to what they should be, but number
two was the Christmas dinner I totally love
scenes like this.
It was kind of a downer episode because somebody
that you're supposed to trust this rip hunter
figure is now totally evil.
So I got really hard-core really fast, but
they find a way to make you feel little bit
better like the Legion of doom has the spear
fragment but they don't have this family that's
going to be important for later episodes because
even though.
The Legion came to an agreement at the end
of last week's episode with the reverse flash
like okay finally were all partners they will
still eat each other alive that just in their
nature they don't have the friendship the
camaraderie that the legends have which is
what that scene was all about number one is
the return of the just a society in the Camelot
episode in two weeks.
So as you saw that star girl in the background.
The way they explain this is that the remaining
Spear fragments of the Spear of destiny or
held by different justice society members
that are hidden across space and time.
So this spear fragment is with star girl in
this Camelot 3000 time.
So like I said, the storyline from the comics
that this is based on was the resurrected
Knights of the round table King Arthur Guinevere
in the year 3000, so it'll be fun to see how
they address the idea of them being mythical
figures from history versus real people citizen
steel is the real historian.
So he'll probably have something to say about
that like King Arthur was he an actual real
person or was he just somebody that was made
up.
So just remember this is the comics, so sometimes
they make fictional people real in the world
of the comics alleges a tomorrow game of thrones
in two weeks to just a reminder that the flash
is on break arrows can be on break to legends
of tomorrow.
So all the DC shows will be on break next
week then I'll come back the week after that.
But I will be doing bonus videos for everything
in the video schedule today is going to be
iron fist footage there's some new footage
will post later tonight then I'll post my
Legion episode one video Thursday morning
then I'll post my arrow video.
Congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner Luke Rizzo please private message me
on the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details, I saw your also subscribe
to my gaming channel Charlie streams if you
guys know I do have again channel.
I don't post there that off the just because
all these normal videos take up my time so
much but I might stream their later this always
links for that in the description if you want
to find out where the other channels I have
are.
I got some new really cool iron fist that
will post later tonight and then I'll update
everybody on the video schedule on twitter
and Facebook as I post new videos you wait
for that to post you can click here for my
flash episode click here for the trailer for
the next episode of the flash thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see the next video!